I'm doing one thing really stupidly that
I should stop doing.
It's like,
how long are you going to take you to
figure out what that is?
It's about two seconds,
right?
You've known it forever.
Then you could even make less demanding.
You could say,
there are some stupid things that I'm
doing that I know are stupid and wrong
that I could stop doing that I would
stop doing,
and then you can just start with that
and you can just do that and maybe it's
just a little thing.
Although it's not because it's.
It's a.
it's a step forward on the proper
voyage.
It's not a small thing and you think,
well,
what would happen?
You could say,
let's do this for a year or even a
month.
Just try not to do things you know,
to be stupid and wrong for a month,
and that means not to say things you
know to be stupid and wrong as well.
Maybe that's the most important thing.
Just do it as an experiment,
see what happens,
and it's so fun because I have people
writing to me from all over the world
who are saying they're doing that.
They're saying,
well,
you know,
I cleaned up my room and,
and then I stopped saying stupid things
and my God,
it's like things are way better.
It's like who would have guessed it?
You know?
And so it's low hanging fruit ban
because that's the other thing.
If there's a lot of things wrong with
you,
then it's really easy to start fixing
it.
You know,
he got so much.
There's so much territory that you can
inhabit.
I will make of thee a great nation.
I will bless thee.
That's good.
I mean the whole nation thing that's
positive,
but to have God on your side,
that's,
you know,
you might want that when things get
rough,
that would be good and make that name
great and thou shalt be a blessing.
Wonderful.
That's a good deal.
Then I will bless them that bless thee.
That's good too.
And curse him that curse thee and in
these shall all families of the earth be
blessed.
That's something that's something that
wouldn't be something if you could wake
up and your day was composed in part of
people thanking you for all the good
things you've done in the world,
would that be good?
It's not impossible for that to happen.
So Abraham departed.
Yes.
As the Lord had spoken unto him and lot
went with him and Abraham was 70 and
five years when he departed out of her
and that's old now.
Abraham lives a long time,
but this is also part of this story.
So he has a wife who can't have
children.
He has nothing.
Obviously.
He's been hanging around dad's shack for
a little too long given that he's 75,
right?
It's time,
it's time to get to the fire lit
underneath and the bath.
And so these not got much going for him,
but he still decides to move forward.
And I've seen this too,
you know,
like if you don't have your destiny in
hand by your time you're 30,
it's rough.
You start hurting and if you don't have
your destiny in hand by the time you're
40 then you really start hurting.
And 40 is a real fork in the road,
the fork in the road.
That's always where you meet the devil
by the way.
And that's because every time you have
to make a decision,
the possibility of evil beckons.
That's why that is.
I had a friend,
I've told you a little about him and he
killed himself just after 40 know he had
had a book published hitting him with a
very small press.
He was quite a good writer,
but he could not get himself together
and it hit him too hard at 40.
And I'm not saying that it's hopeless at
40.
I'm not saying that and I'm not saying
that partly because of these verses,
but also partly because of what I've
seen in my clinical practice.
I've had people come to me who have had
very chaotic and ill spent lives,
let's say,
who were in that neighborhood of age
and.
And it's true for people who are older
as well,
who then decided to make a real effort
and to try to make where they were
better.
You know,
instead of being bitter about where they
weren't.
Because
that's the bitterness that really does
you,
when it's really not good.
It's the opposite of gratitude.
It's,
it's,
it's the manifestation of resentment.
It makes you malevolent.
It's very,
very bad to be better.
It's not,
it's not.
It's hell to be bitter,
and if you're 40 and you're not
successful,
then you have to accept your lot and you
have to start to improve what's right in
front of you.
And if you do that,
it doesn't take very long.
It's quite interesting to watch people.
Things can be a lot better in six months
and they can be way better in two years.
Like it's a struggle,
uphill struggle,
but it's by no means impossible.
And I don't know again what the limit of
that is.
I suppose it depends to a degree to some
degree on the degree of your commitment,
but anyway,
so aber,
it's another indication of the real
validity of this story.
God isn't setting this up to be easy,
right?
Abraham was old and he and and his and
his wife is old to and more than that,
she's barren.
How is he going to be the father of
nations?
How is he going to be successful?
Well,
the initial departure point is
insufficient,
radically insufficient,
and that's very inspiring because it
means that you can start from where you
are.